it's a big deal for the community it's
going to be a market where
our communities can be proud of
we're adding a bakery we're adding
almost 50 new feet of produce
we're bringing in wick
something that's not around here that
the families don't have
um
we're really going to try and make it a
a beautiful store we're going to make
and i think i said we're going to try
we're going to make it available that we
are proud of
and i mean we i mean the community and
the 89106 the historic west side
to
have a place where they can call theirs
because that's who it is i mean my name
may be on the building but it's the
community store
it's a store where
everybody knows each other
it's a it's a place where
if
uh you know somebody says well what's
the difference between you and smith's
are you in one of these big chains the
difference is that if say a family
member passes you can't go to you can't
go over the big chains and put a jar up
on the me calendar and say i need we
need to collect some money to marry one
of my family members here in the
community our store
we do that
we help
the community because without the
community i'm really nobody
you know
i i need the community and and i have
the community